face à la première
bienvenue à toutes et à tous d'en face à
la première repose un premier
rendez-vous de la saison dans une
formule renouvelée en direct sur nos
réseaux sociaux non seulement sur notre
site internet rla premiere.fr mais
également sur le compte facebook de
martinique première et en radio donc le
dimanche à 12 heures pour ce premier
numéro actualité oblige vous propose un
échange sur le thème du dérèglement du
climat sur la planète et de ses
conséquences ion de notre vie
quotidienne avec nos invités tout
d'abord à ma droite le professeur pascal
ça fâche bonjour promet serge bonjour tu
rappelles que vous êtes géographe de
formation et que vous enseignez la
géographie et l'aménagement à
l'université des antilles et à ma gauche
marseillais n'a donne 20 jours
l'ancienne ado jean corti bonjour à
toutes les auditrices et tous les
auditeurs mère du prêcheur un militant
écologiste porte parole du mouvement nos
peuples a entre autres activités
responsabilités et donc
nous je choisi de proposer cet échange
aujourd'hui en raison de l'accumulation
de phénomènes climatiques et j'allais
dire non pas extraordinaire puisque nous
sommes dans la saison cyclonique habitué
aux ouragans mais de la puissance de ces
éléments
à l'heure où nous parlons il est encore
un peu trop tôt pour évoquer les dégâts
et de l'ouragan et on m'a et de
l'ouragan jose mais une première
question messieurs la puissance
exceptionnelle de l'aura d'un événement
qui a battu le record si je ne m'abuse
de niveau de classe 5 qu'il est il est
temps il reste un classique quasiment 40
heures est dû au réchauffement du climat
parce qu'elle s'attachait j'ai dit vrai
ou faux disons que vous êtes dans la
réalité c'est à dire que s'il est
toujours difficile un d'établir des
liens au cif aussi franc aussi ferme
entre la puissance vraiment des ouragans
et le dérèglement climatique parce que
c'est vrai que des règlements climatique
on lui on lui attribue beaucoup de
choses
il n'empêche que on sait maintenant en
tout cas les modèles indiquent ce sont
des modèles de météo france mais des
modèles d'autres organismes aussi
internationaux indiquent en raison du
réchauffement climatique les ouragans
seront de plus en plus puissants et là
on en a un très bel exemple puisque
c'est l'une des premières fois en tout
cas de l'histoire humaine
j'ai envie de dire précisément qui a été
traduite par des faits par des éléments
quantifiable parce qu'on a des
descriptions du passé qui sont elles
aussi très intéressante et qui décrivent
des phénomènes extraordinairement
violent mais à l'époque on sait très
bien qu'on n'avait pas les moyens de
quantifier les phénomènes de façon aussi
précise et donc de façon contemporaine
de façon relativement récente il
semblerait que ce soit le phénomène le
plus violent que nous ayons connue sur
le bassin atlantique et donc puisqu'on
est en phase de réchauffement climatique
et puisqu'on sait que l'ouragan se
nourrit de la chaleur et comme on sait
que le réchauffement climatique c'est
justement ça à une élévation de la
température des basses couches de
l'atmosphère le lien en effet était sans
quasi évident entre réchauffement
climatique et ce phénomène vraiment
exceptionnel alors quoi il est
exceptionnel c'est son intensité c'est
sa durée c'est sa puissance ce qui est
ce qu'il aura exceptionnelle tout
d'abord c'est ça la classe qu'il a
atteint la catégorie qu'il a une
catégorie 5
je rappelle quand même que hugo
quand même marqué les mémoires hugo est
un ouragan de catégorie 4 qui a atteint
la catégorie 5 momentanément pendant
quelques heures et après qui a été à
nouveau des classe et en classe 4
donc là on a un phénomène qui reste un
class 5 pendant quasiment 40 heures
deuxièmement ce qu'il aura
exceptionnelle aussi c'est que c'est un
phénomène qui est très gras masse est
très concentré contrairement à des
ouragans qui parfois peuvent atteindre
des diamètres de 900km 1000 km là on a
un phénomène qui fait grossièrement 500
kilomètres donc très concentré mais avec
des vents prés du centre très bien eu
près de l'oeil qui sont d'une violence
inouïe 1 320 kilomètres heure
certaines rafales mesurer à 340 km heure
donc on comprend que les dégâts de toute
façon ne pouvait autres être autres que
ceux qui ont été observés romain soler
nadeau en tant que élu local maire d'une
commune d'une part et d'autre part en
tant que militant écologiste vous avez
été militant avant d'être maire mme c
est que ce n'est pas innocent de le
souligner il y a de quoi être perplexe
sachant que les écologistes sur la
planète
de manière générale met en garde depuis
un demi siècle
tout le monde les autorités les
institutions les organismes les
individus sur le réchauffement
climatique qui peut précipiter qui peut
générer qui peut produire des
dérèglements des phénomènes naturels de
ce genre alors c'est vrai que bon les
cyclones ouragans y en a toujours eu
mais c'est vrai aussi que les
écologistes pendant longtemps dit ce qu'
il fallait s'attendre compte tenu de la
réalité qui n'est pas seulement on parle
de changement climatique je dirais avec
un auteur d'ailleurs qui se revendiquent
de l'écosocialisme de basculement
climatique
c'est vrai que on y est donc qui
prévoyait affectif effectivement des
phénomènes exceptionnels
c'est vrai comme l'a dit le professeur
ça fasse que jusqu'à présent dans la
zone caraïbes ou n'avait pas épargné un
petit peu par ce type de phénomène mais
vraiment il est aux manettes un cas
exceptionnel qui montrent que que les
écologistes d'une part à verizon
mais il ne s'agit pas de ces ne
recueillir du fait qu on ait eu raison
avec toi avant tout le monde non si je
pense que la conscience notre conscience
écologique nous pousse bien sûr à a
milité pour que des mesures soient
prises des mesures pour effectivement
réduire les conséquences du
réchauffement climatique et réduire
autant que possible
le phénomène du réchauffement climatique
lui-même mais en attendant le temps
qu'on y arrive je pense qu'il faut aussi
prendre des mesures préventives
il faut adapter à la fois les politiques
d'aménagement et à ces risques là il
faut aussi développer une culture du
risque pour deux manières apparaît au
moins plus pressé pour ne pas subir
comme ça s'efface et martin saint
barthélémy et dans les autres villes
concernées de la caraïbe
ce type de phénomène dont vous êtes en
train de me dire que le réchauffement du
climat à l'échelle de la planète est une
donnée naturelle certes mais sur
laquelle l'homme peut et doit agir
seddiki un aspect naturel vin comme on
sonne le phénomène mais a aussi un
aspect brondy anthropique anthropique ça
vous savourez dire que c'est lié à
l'activité humaine les années pas
n'importe quelle activité humaine moi je
suis là haut sur militants politiques
jouent qu'il faut poser des questions
c'est vrai que depuis la révolution
industrielle le développement du
capitalisme on assiste à une logique
économique qui est celle de
l'accumulation celle de la cupidité
comme dirait un certain économique n'est
ce pas au détriment faveur de l'intérêt
taux de l'intérêt commun de l'intérêt
général de l'intérêt collectif
donc il s'agit de il s'agit
effectivement de changer de logique de
changer la logique du système de pensée
plus l'intérêt de l'homme de l'aude
l'intérêt des communautés que c'est la
fict avant des intérêts privés et du
profit d'autant qu'on le sait bien en
réalité ces phénomènes ils sont
naturelles mais particulièrement injuste
qui est-ce qui profite plus d'aider des
raisons des causes du réchauffement
climatique c'est quand même les sociétés
occidentales et une minorité de nantis
alors que ceux qui subissent les
conséquences ce sont les pays du sud et
les plus pauvres dans les sociétés dites
développées
je crois qu'il faut bien se rendre
compte de tout ça et c'est vous sac en
tant que militant politique en tant que
militant écologiste de l'écologie
politique n'est pas seulement une
question d'environnement
une problématique environnementale hills
elle est aussi profondément politique
parce que au-delà des questions dont
parle le buzzer ça fâche avec brio et
que j'apprécie beaucoup et bien des
questions de fond les questions
politiques sur lesquels nous devons nous
positionner et une analyse que vous
partagez sacha fâche sur l'impact de les
truies de l'activité des hommes sur
l'intensification
extraordinaire de certains phénomènes
naturels oui façon l'analyse elle et
elle est totalement juste elle est
totalement injuste dans la mesure où
l'on sait pertinemment que ces
phénomènes sont des phénomènes à la base
qui sont naturels et c'est d'ailleurs
tout le débat qui lie avec les
climato-sceptiques qui disent de toute
façon ce sont des phénomènes qui se
serait développé en dehors de la
présence de l'homme ce qui est pas tout
à fait exact dans la mesure où s'il est
vrai que ces phénomène de réchauffement
est ce qu'on sait très bien que la terre
a connu des cycles et qu'elle fonctionne
par cycles donc il ya eu des glaciations
il ya eu des phases de réchauffement et
c'est donc c'est très bien que l'homme
par ses actions et c'est vrai que c'est
l'avènement du capitalisme qui est à
l'origine de ces deux de ces facteurs de
ces phénomènes
l'homme par ses actions a accentué un
certain nombre de deux paramètres
paramètres qui ont dérégulé l'ensemble
du système et à partir du moment où le
système est dérégulé
mais il s'emballe et là on est dans une
phase vraiment d'emballement donc on a
cru d'ailleurs après la coop 21 qu'il y
avait une sorte de sursaut et que le
monde allait réagir dans le monde a en
partie réagi mais on s'aperçoit que deux
ans après cette coupe 21 il y a encore
des personnes qui sont prêtes à faire
machine arrière qui sont prêtes à dire
mais on arrête tout parce que
fondamentalement ça ne sert pas nos
sociétés ça ne sert pas nos intérêts et
on est prêt à sacrifier l'intérêt global
d'intérêt général pour une poignée
d'individus qui de toute façon font du
profit continuer à faire du profit sur
en faisant les autres pâtir de leur
profiter de qui parlez-vous on parle on
parle essentiellement des
multinationales des grandes des grandes
puissances qui sont suffisamment riches
pour faire du lobby du lobbying à tout
va et pour influencer le lait comme un
dirais-je les décisions qui sont prises
par certains gouvernements
on le voit le convoi la position du
président trump c'est une position qui
devra qui doit interpeller naturellement
parce que en réalité les plus grands
scientifiques et pas des moindres des
prix nobel fine fin indique très
clairement
chiffres à l'appui que si des mesures
drastiques ne sont pas prises maintenant
est en réalité loin du duo président ya
déjà vingt ans mais si elles ne sont pas
prises maintenant le système va
s'emballer de telle sorte qu'il sera
ingérable dans les années à venir quand
on voit quand on voit ce qui s'est passé
avec irma quand on voit ce qui se passe
à travers le monde
depuis quelques années on devrait
véritablement mais tous se regarder dans
la même direction et tous agir en faveur
de la protection de deux fins en faveur
du bien commun du bien collectif et on
s'aperçoit qu'on en est encore à
raisonner de façon parcellaire de façon
individualiste pour privilégier tel ou
tel groupe tel ou tel intérêt
alors que l'intérêt global n'est pas
prise en compte là il faut bien prendre
conscience d'une chose et je m'excuse
être aussi grave
en disant cela il faut bien prendre
conscience d'une chose c'est que là
enfin c'est un c'est une formule que
j'emploie que depuis quelques années
mais je crois qu'on est vraiment arrivé
à la croisée des chemins
nous y sommes si des mesures concrètes
ferme et définitive ne sont pas prises
dans les années à venir
ce sont les marionnettes de le disais
tout à l'heure ce sont encore les mêmes
qui vont payer
mais cette fois ci ils vont payer cessé
même entre guillemets que je préfère ne
pas citer vont encore payer ils vont
payer encore plus durement et plus
chèrement et plus fréquemment et de quoi
s'agit-il
il s'agit de d'agir en faveur du
réchauffement climatique et donc pour
faire pour casser ce réchauffement
climatique pour le faire pour le limiter
tout au moins dans un premier temps
parce que malheureusement on sait que le
phénomène va ne va faire que croître
alors on va devenir de revenir à la
martinique je signale que nous avons
donnent la caravelle caraïbes pour la
première fois de notre histoire des
réfugiés climatiques ainsi une catégorie
de la population qui est obligé de
quitter son habitat provisoirement ou
définitivement en raison de la survenue
d'un phénomène naturel majeur et il
s'agit des 1600 habitants de l'île de
batz review d'après de antigua donc au
nord de la guadeloupe entre guadeloupe
et porto rico peuvent situer sur la
carte de géographie et qui sont qui ont
été évacuées et donc ça veut dire que ce
genre de scénario peut se répercuter à
lyon et pourquoi pas en martinique mais
cela n'a donc vous qui êtes maire du
prêcheur une commune située sur le
littoral qui est grignotée après année
après année le parce que professeur ça
fâche a été donnée promis un tigre la
cnda monsieur ça ça vous parle à la
notion réfugiés climatiques chez nous
oui mais bien sûr d'une pas bon c'est
vrai que c'est bon c'est vous
vous disais que c'était nouveau je crois
que bon déjà les réfugiés climatiques
économiques une ténèbres ication entre
les réalités économiques et les réalités
climatiques qu'on ne sait pas si par
exemple ceux de nos frères haïtiens qui
des fois doivent quitter leur pays c'est
du bois des raisons économiques
évidentes mais petit froid quelquefois à
des raisons économiques liées aux
conditions climatiques aux conditions
notamment de développement du système
agricole je dois dire aussi que nous
avons connu pas des réfugiés climatiques
mais des réfugiés liée à des phénomènes
naturels la 1902 il est prêt je t'aide
et les réfugiés
et d'ailleurs je ne sais pas si c'est un
clin d'oeil de l'histoire du contexte
mais il ya notamment un très bel article
qui a été commis par les hausses eu les
dents le france antilles d'aujourd'hui
celui d'hier qui parle du son de la
gestion de la crise au 2900 de gare en
parlant justement de l'irruption du 30
août
je crois que c'est très intéressant mais
il disait aussi parce qu'il faut qu'on
s'habitue aussi aux migrations et quand
on voit la manière dont sont traités les
migrants quelqu'il soit 10 soit
climatiques économiques ou politiques
on a on n'a rien vu je crois que ça peut
être inquiétant et en martinique par
exemple les eaux sud est dit très
justement que les les réfugiés liées
justement la catastrophe de la plaie
était profondément méprisés comme
d'ailleurs en guadeloupe les habitants
de basse terre était méprisé par ceux de
pointe à pitre vrille que moi sur de
petits territoires dix fois dans la
question se pose mais tend effectivement
et on a déjà connu donc ce type de
migration parce qu'en 1902 ailleurs je
rends hommage et ses hauts lieux et les
reçu lui aussi qui me l'avait suggéré le
fait qu'on ait baptisé une salle on est
dénommée félix gaulle est fêlé ce bol
était le maire du prêcheur de 1902 et
qui avait organisé avec les autorités
l'évacuation de sa population et qui
étale à se battre contre des dégradés de
l'armée française qui ne respectaient
pas sa population dans la zone de fond
là il ne pouvait donc c'est des choses
qui reviennent sur ça je crois que
l'histoire donc il ya le tout le travail
qui est fait par la profession ça fâche
sur la la géographie les questions
climatiques etc mais aussi le travail
que pourrait faire des historiens sur la
question de la jce
sion de ce type de crise parce que le
travail que les hausses eu d'effet me
paraît intéressant parce qu'il puis le
monde que moi la crise a pu être gérée
ou comment elle aurait pu être géré il
est évident que moi mais évidemment on
pourrait être confronté à ce type soit
pour un cyclone ce soit pour une
éruption soit pour un séisme je ne sais
quoi
confronté à ce type de situation alors
là il faut effectivement qu'on y
réfléchisse comme on y va qu'une
population comment on constitue des
lieux de refuge
comment on développe deux des réflexes
aussi etc je vois que c'est ce tout ce
travail que nous devons faire tous mes
enfants du parce qu on a l'habitude de
dire comme très souvent au moyen des
zones qui sont des questions liées aux
risques littoraux comme le prêcheur qui
sont un peu plus exposés on se tourne
facilement vers le prêcheur non c'est
toute la martinique toute la martinique
dans ce pays qui est confronté à tous
les risques sauf le risque avalanche
qu'on voit justement s'interroger sur un
banc une véritable stratégie de mise en
place déjà en terme d'aménagement parce
qu'il faut penser l'aménagement
autrement on le passe aujourd'hui et à
terme d'organisation des secours
à terme de préparation des populations
justement à un éventuel déplacement si
le professeur à sa phase je relisais ya
quelques jours encore au premier article
sur le grignotage du littoral notamment
dans le nom caraïbes entre eux en disant
en gros la zone comprise entre 40 et
prêcheurs ou à vous disiez donc c'était
dans l'est au début des années 1990 ne
sont que vous avez déjà en 1992 94 sur
ça nous sommes en 2010 est tout de même
on a l'impression que bombay
en tant que scientifique même si vous
êtes écoutez vous n'êtes pas forcément
entendu par les autorités en général
l'état les élus locaux mais également la
population c'est aller au monsieur
madame tout le monde
on dit généralement que nul n'est
prophète en son pays donc il faut croire
que c'est vrai mais c'est vrai que ça
fait quand même quelques quelques années
à une tête presque une vingtaine
d'années maintenant que les mêmes choses
sont répétées elles sont répétées mais
j'ai un peu le sentiment qu'elle porte
peut-être un peu plus maintenant parce
que les réalités commence à s'imposer à
nous d'en au début des années 90 bon
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu quelques
catastrophes naturelles on peut penser à
cindy on peut penser à des phénomènes de
ce type mais la population n'était
peut-être pas encore suffisamment
peut-être touché peut-être pas
suffisamment du doigt ces réalités et
aujourd'hui en tout cas les images sont
particulièrement choquant ce qu'on voit
ce qui ce qui ce qui se passe à saint
martin est particulièrement choquant ce
qui se passe à travers le monde et
suffisamment choquant et suffisamment
violent pour que les uns et les autres
commencent qui est une sorte de prise de
conscience qui commencent à poindre
néanmoins néanmoins même si cette prise
de conscience est intéressante au niveau
de la population parce que c'est quand
même c'est de cette population qui devra
agir ou réagir
il n'empêche que on a un peu le
sentiment qu'il y a que la machine est
quand même mais lente à se mettre en
mouvement à se mettre en marche pour que
des décisions très concrètes soient
prises par exemple la problématique de
la relocalisation des populations
côtières pour ne prendre que cet exemple
puisqu'on parle du ragon parle de risque
lié aux milieux marins cette
problématique est une problématique qui
chez nous aurait dû être la
problématique majeure
tout le monde aurait dû s'en saisir que
ce soit les collectivités territoriales
les municipalités enfin qu'il sera dû
être vraiment la problématique le fil
directeur de notre je veux dire de la
politique locale de la politique
territoriale se soit pas d explication
de texte sont pas des informations que
les maires que les aujourd'hui les élus
de la ctm est également l'état le
gouvernement quelle que soit la
coloration politique de ce gouvernement
ce n'est pas d'information dont il moque
nom n'est pas d'informations dont la
population les gens qui construisent des
maisons des restaurants
qui ont des activités sur le bord du
littoral ce n'est pas de l'information
dont nous manquons façon je pense pas
que ce soit les informations qui
manquera c'est sûr
peut-être que le politique pourra
peut-être y répondre plus facilement
puisque ce sont des décisions politiques
qui doivent être prises mais il
n'empêche que oui moi - le seul constat
que je peux faire c'est que
malheureusement ça n'avance que très
très très lentement
est ce que je crains malheureusement
c'est que dans les années à venir
ces problématiques s'impose à nous plus
que nous n'arrivions véritablement à les
dominer à les anticiper et là on voit
bien ce qui s'est passé à saint martin
mais je crains véritablement que demain
elle s'impose à nous mais avec une
violence vaille à josé qui arrive on ne
sait pas ce qui se produira avant il ya
de fortes chances qu'il passe quand même
au large de la martinique est beaucoup
plus au nord mais il n'empêche que
soyons très prudent parce que je crains
que la réalité s'impose à nous très très
vite voir alors là je parle à un maire
qui a déjà réfléchi avec soi que ces
municipales sa population sur la
question à lui poser une question
provocatrice ce jeudi soir il y a eu
dans le magazine envoyé spécial sur
france 2
reportage qui porte sur l'érosion du
littoral dans le bassin en cachant dans
le sud de la france envoie 60 km de
bordeaux sur l'océan atlantique et il se
peut que effectivement toutes les
prévisions montrent que d'ici 20 ans la
moitié de la ville de lacanau peuplé de
40000 habitants tout de même c'est pas
300 personnes sera submergé par la mer
et le groupe la difficulté la
problématique de la municipalité de
faire un référendum demandé à la
population aux opérateurs économiques
le rider de déménager une partie de la
ville un peu plus à l'intérieur des
terres
est-ce que vous en êtes prêt au prêcheur
je voudrais dire le professeur sa vache
peut en témoigner que nous sommes une
miss val it est très consciente du
risque des risques littoraux en général
et de la problématique du trait de codes
et de l'érosion côtière en particulier
et d'ailleurs je
il m'est souvent raconté qu'un ancien
parlementaire m très souvent à dire que
vous savez pour faire prendre conscience
de la réalité de l'érosion côtière que
vous savez que le prêcheur à disparaître
un jour il à la fois tort et raison
il a raison parce que effectivement si
on n'y fait rien si on ne fait rien oui
je risque de disparaître entre
communautés à risque et la calabre
israël soumet du peu mais je suis je
reste humble quand même pour l'humanité
parce que chaque communauté humaine qui
disparaît c'est un appauvrissement pour
l'humanité je le crois profondément
mais il alla il à être aussi parce que
en réalité je pense que nous avons la
volonté d'anticiper et d'ailleurs de le
prouver sur sa tâche a très récemment
commis une étude nouvelle étude sur la
question de l'érosion côtière au
prêcheur qui sera présenté au mois de
novembre
mais nous avons aussi pu bénéficier d'un
appel à idées du ministère de l'écologie
qui a retenu une école d'architecturé en
l'occurrence l'école de marne la vallée
pour réaliser une étude justement sur
l'avenir du littoral par rapport aux
changements climatiques est bon bien
avez ça aboie toi avec tes réflexions
nous allons déjà menées y compris que le
procès sur sa face nous étions déjà
orientés vers l'idée d'une ce qu'on
pourrait appeler une transition
territoriales savez vous que sur la
question des risques
il y a même des municipalités qui font
des événementiels festif autour de
risque c'est une manière de développer
la culture de l'espérance une zone
inondable quand elle m'a islandais pour
faire prendre conscience faire
comprendre
noman et cetera donc on essaie
d'organiser des événements intéressants
mais je crois ce que met en effet comme
ça encore il s'est pas fait parce encore
ici c'est dommage mais on veut justement
va y arriver du prêcheur on voudrait
justement être par exemple la trêve
estivale et la musicale mais si vous
avez l'armée combat mais pas en faire en
face il va bouffer un festival aux
éditions naïve et 4 mai pour faire
prendre conscience justement de nos
réalités physiques parce que on a
l'impression que les gens vivent sur
mars
on a besoin d'eux des martiniquais ne
sont pas en martinique la martinique est
un pays avec ses réalités géographiques
physiques climatique et c'est ce qu'on
appelle la résilience et je crois que
nous avons pris conscience de la
nécessité de réagir par rapport à la
réalité des régions côtières à travers
une transition que nous appelons une
tranchante et étudiants qui consiste à
faire quoi et bien fait remonter le bo
vers les hauteurs là se pose la question
du foncier agricole
est-ce qu'on est tenu de reprendre le
modèle occidental d'un zonage street où
on a des zones habitées des zones
cultivées des hommes c'est là le truc de
la zona logique de la zone est ce qu'on
va sortir de cette zone est retrouvée
comme ils étaient deux trous de coutume
de l'avoir prêcher la tradition des
cases vous aviez une exploitation
agricole avec une habitation des
habitations etc permettent aux gens
aujourd'hui roues donc vous attendre
imagine que vous rentrerez fléchir à
faire migrer le prochain de fait sa
population derrière l'intérieur cela
zucchero peut comprendre comment ça va
très vite les gens sur les contreforts
de jeu pour l'exemple du prêcheur
historique moi je joue là aussi je pense
que les soins de beauté
les six bons on à rimbaud fortement
littoral iseo veille
c'est donc avec une forte implantation
humaine mais vous savez que dans les
avants 1902 il y avait des habitants qui
s'avale mettons pense pas avoir d
habitat mais y en avait mais les gens
ont fui le risque volcanique
parce que c'était le risque naturel le
plus avérée donc ils sont allés sur la
frange littorale en se disant qu'ils
seront mieux placés en cas d'évacuation
c'est top c'est une sous cet angle c'est
un axe stratégique d'évacuation mais
aujourd'hui comme on est notamment grâce
aux travaux des universités matic et
qu'on pose sur sa vache de plus en plus
conscience de la réalité des risques
littoraux
il faut revoir la copie en essayant de
trouver des modèles d'aménagement qui
prenne en compte tous les risques
quel qu'il soit y compris ceux des
glissements et aux prêcheurs ce travail
qu'ils étaient faits par ces jeunes
d'architectes nous permet avec l'état
d'ailleurs parce qu'il ya deuxième vice
interministérielle qui travaillent avec
nous parce que c'est pas c'est pas une
sorte de 10 d un petit peu vague non
c'est un projet concret et d'ailleurs
l'idée qu'ils étaient proposés par les
architectes c'est de se dire on va
d'abord faire un équipement public dans
les zones dans les hauteurs du prêcheur
vers préville d'invitation dréville un
équipement public qui sera une école
parce que notre école est exposée aux
risques notamment du lard de la rivière
du prix dollar de la rivière du prêcheur
les enfants qui ont l'habitude d'aller à
l'école ils y vont plus facilement vers
leur école en cas de catastrophe ils
l'école sera aussi un refuge parce que
je parlais tout à l'heure à vocation en
sera le refuge avec du stockage avec des
locaux adaptés à l'accueil des ddd
d'aider des personnes qui peuvent être
victimes de la catastrophe
est ce que la situation reste figée
sensibles à ça parce que là ça s'annonce
à de mono j'ai l'habitude d'abandonner
leurs maisons
non mais leurs habitudes mais je sais
que j'en rate la vie évident quand on a
vu le cas de la solide à la cité de la
solidarité puisque le cad
après la suite de lenny c'est vrai qu'on
a construit très rapidement une sorte de
cité cap et accueillir des gens mais une
fois que le danger était passé
les gens sont certaines personnes sont
retournées vers la mer surtout considéré
des activités liées à la mer c'était des
marins pêcheurs et chaque fois qu'ils
ont un problème
un risque quelconque que la météo
annonce au mauvais temps et retourne
vers ses habitations de la cité de la
solidarité et la sam était interrogée ça
veut dire je vous dis pourquoi parce que
en parlais tout à l'heure de
relocalisation il y à la conception
continental de leur poste une stratégie
dans la stratégie de la mer et du
littoral nationale française m il pose
le problème de la roque la
relocalisation des activités des biens
sauf quand on en milieux continental
c'est une relocalisation définitive
alors que ceux qui ont occupé notre
territoire je peux je veux parler des
cayes notamment il avait une forme de
mobilité qui s'adaptait aussi aux
conditions physiques douzaine il
occupait la l'espace marin il vivait
près de la mer mais ils allaient dans
des zazous pas au fin fond de la forêt
pour faire des cueillettes ou cultivées
et c'est donc y avait cette mobilité que
nous devons retrouver pourquoi parce que
nous n'avons pas des territoires aussi
étendus qu'un territoire continental se
tait les trois exils
vu donc il faut qu'on apprenne à être
mobile pour pouvoir justement s'adapter
aux risques et il faut pas dire que ça
ne peut pas être fait parce que en
guadeloupe par exemple à des et bien les
habitants 2d qui occupait le bout qui
vivaient et qui avait activités
commerciales à force d'être victime de
houle ont compris qu'il fallait sauver
la saison ils ont leur habitation à
l'intérieur des terres mais ont gardé
leur commerce sur la frange littorale
c'est une forme de mobilité qui peut
servir d'exemple pour justement que des
orientations maintient votre santé parce
qu'elles sachent pas ce que vous allez
vous avez contact avec quasiment tous
les maires les autorités administratives
politiques du pays est ce que cette
prise de conscience mans est ce qu'il ya
des exemples des plans il ya celui de
pression et à notre commune également
car mais surtout réfléchi sur les six
qui va relocaliser certains services
publics pensent que des axes routiers
prévoir des places pour la mettre la
population est ce que il ya des choses
qu'on y arrivera dans la génération qui
arrive parce que en fait là la nature
n'attend pas la nature n'attend pelle
nous attendra pas une chose est sûre
c'est que la ccc le bon exemple c'est
vraiment l'archétype de ceux de la
commune où on réfléchit à ces questions
c'est vraiment le prêcheur je ne le dis
pas parce que j'aime être en face de moi
mais c'est parce que c'est une réalité
bon il y à a été dit il y à trinité il
ya le carbet saint-pierre aussi
commencent à se positionner parce qu'il
ya quelques réflexions qui sont menées
mais normalement les toutes les communes
littorales devrait devrait réagir et je
vais vous dire pourquoi tout devrait
réagir parce que j'ai tout à l'heure
marcenat l'un d'eux disait que c'est un
vrai problème le premier l'aménagement
son problème de la martinique c'est un
problème seulement des communes côtières
c'est tout à fait exact parce que le
problème de notre territoire c'est que
nous l'avons aménagé bon alors à
l'époque ça répondait à certaines
logiques l'idée n'est pas ici de
critiquer ceux ceux qui sont à l'origine
de ces logiques mais à l'époque on est
aménagé la martinique par petits bouts
parakou par segment et chacun avait sa
logique d'aménagement problème c'est que
pour qu'un aménagement fonctionne il
faut avoir une vision globale c'est un
petit peu comme si vous vous trouvez
dans un avion vous regardez le
territoire du haut
vous en avez une vue totalement
je veux dire synoptique une vue une vue
globale et à ce moment vous pouvez
prendre conscience des forces et des
faiblesses du territoire
mais si vous restez au sol et que vous
aménager le pas de votre devant le pas
de votre porte fondamentalement ça vous
avons tiré un patchwork qui est
totalement incohérent et problème c'est
qu'en martinique
chaque maire a voulu son aménagement
chaque collectivité a voulu son
aménagement ces prêts à être jalouse de
ses prérogatives et on aboutit
aujourd'hui à une sorte de vraiment de
méli mélo de patchwork où chacun a son
petit objet son petit voilà sa petite
référence sans qu' il y ait une vue
globale et une cohérence d'ensemble est
ce que la création et la montée en
puissance des trois communautés
d'agglomération kacem espace sud cap nom
n'est pas de nature à inverser cette
tendance en quelque sort normalement ça
devrait ça devrait être le cas mais je
crois surtout que l'outil qui va être
vraiment l'outil de base de cette
comment dirais-je de ceux de ce travail
c
comment dirais-je l'ancien je suis un
peu fatigué ce après midi c'est le le
schéma régional plus sympathique mais je
pense que c'est ça oui qui normalement
doit être revue et fondamentalement je
crois que pour le revoir et pour le
revoir pour qu'il soit pertinent
il faut véritablement qu'on arrête ces
visions qui sont des visions secto
sectorielle sectorisé mais avoir une
vision vraiment global de l'ensemble du
territoire et moi j'avoue que je formule
vraiment le souhait que ce soir ou en
tout cas enfin ce document ce soit
vraiment partager avec le plus grand
nombre de façon à ce qu'on aboutisse à
quelque chose de cohérent et non plus
ces petites touches qui peuvent parfois
peuvent être intéressantes mais qui ne
sont que de petites touches ici à droite
à gauche sans qu'il n'y ait vraiment
cette espèce de cohérence globale
en clair nous savons qu'il y attendre
d'aller en sentant de risque certain
nombre de dangers liés à la nature a
beaucoup parlé de l'érosion littorale
puisque la majorité de la population de
martinique vie dans les villes contient
c'est comme ça c'est l'histoire cela on
ne revient pas sur l'histoire coloniale
qui imposait aux habitations d'être non
loin de la mer etc ou d'une rivière
est-ce qu'il n'est pas trop tard pour
inverser cette annonce parce que s'ils
voient qu'il ya l'information s'ils
voient qu'il ya beaucoup de place
finalement dit que la lentille question
peuplée mais en même temps il ya des
pans entiers du territoire qui sont
inhabitées inoccupés non construit il ya
pas de réseau routier quoi que ce soit
ce qui n'est qu'il est encore possible
d'aménager le pays le territoire
différemment bon monsieur est bon alors
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup d'erreurs
qui ont été faites et puis bon c'est par
méconnaissance des fois maintenant les
20 niveaux de connaissance qui nous qui
nous permet aujourd'hui de prendre
d'autres de faire d'autres choix mais
n'est jamais trop tard en fait il n'est
jamais trop tard au moins parce que je
sais plus cette formule de camus qui dit
bon moment sans vouloir refaire le monde
ou mots ne pas le défaire en effet
éviter que notre pays se défasse et je
crois que pour ce n est pas trop tard
il suffit effectivement comme l'a dit le
fossé professeur ça fâche déjà de revoir
un petit peu les logiques de gouvernance
sortir de l'esprit de clocher
avoir une vision globale et transversale
du territoire pensé que nous ne sommes
pas seuls au monde nourrit aussi des
relations que vous expliquez que nous
sommes à quelques comme disait premier
ministre de saint kitts et nevis un jet
de pierre des actifs de la guadeloupe se
manger moins de changer de pierre de
roseaux on n'a aucune relation sur la
question des secours par exemple parce
qu'on sait bien que tous les
spécialistes des risques
tous les spécialistes urgentistes nous
disent que mais le prône la paix
blessent un divorce et votre voisin
c'est celui qui est tout près bon
entendus dans le quartier dans la maison
vous voulez mais aussi une balle dans le
pied
quelles sont les relations que nous
développons notamment en termes des
changes
alors je sais qu'à l'époque où j'étais
conseiller général et on avait constitué
une sorte de pôle de réflexion des pays
de 2 d'une sur deux clusters avec les
pays de la carie pour réfléchir sur nos
problématiques justement de risques on
années de ces relations que fait-on
concrètement donc il ya tout ça à mettre
en place et et puis je crois aussi qu'il
faut pouvoir affronter un certain nombre
de l'aube il a aussi s'est il faut
sortir du tout déplacement du tout
pétrole du tout voiture passait la
relocalisation de l'économie
penser la proximité etc moi je crois
qu'effectivement il faut la question des
risques est une entrée et c'est un
indicateur de l'état d'un pays
aujourd'hui la question des risques la
manière dont ils sont traités dernier
nous les vivons à travers notamment
notre aménagement est révélateur de la
réalité sociale économique politique de
la martinie enfin déjà en termes de
modèle que nous voulons absolument
reproduit toujours des modèles notre
frilosité sur la question de
l'application des textes
on parlait tout à l'heure de
relocalisation et de stratégie de
relocalisation mais c'est des choses qui
sont pensés pour des jeux les dit tout à
l'heure des espaces continentaux il faut
et je crois aujourd'hui la seule chance
pour s'en sortir
c'est notre détermination notre audace à
innover à expérimenter ce que je dis y'a
peut-être pas une solution qui va là
pour tous les territoires
maintenant il est intéressant
effectivement d'innover d'expérimenter
des choses sur certains territoires
bien évidemment après il il faut
absolument évaluer les résultats de
manière à les étendre
et je pense que c'est ces niveaux c'est
à dire un niveau où on peut expérimenter
des choses et après la possibilité
d'étendre l'ensemble d'un territoire
donnez nous écoutent d'expérimentation
que l'on pourrait mener à l'échelle d'un
quartier d'une rue ou d'une commune à
martinique qu'elle pourrait juger pour
un exemple très simple il est dit aussi
que vous savez le lisseur quand on parle
du jeu disait que la question des
risques et transverses quand vous prenez
la question du lien social va pas aller
vous encourez initier nos pas nous
parents les boîtes yun cai l'autre nous
fâcher beauvoisin qu'arracher note pour
des futilités quelquefois mais vous
savez que ça peut avoir une incidence au
niveau des secours parce que on dit que
le temps est très important pour porter
secours une personne le voisin j'ai vous
si fâchés plus bas break à elie yshaï
réfléchir ou peut-être quand moore avons
fait alors que le lien social on peut
aussi faire un travail dans un quartier
expérimenter la relation entre le lien
social risque mais il ya des choses
qu'on peut faire démocratie
participative et présente le référent de
quartier on saura que martel et et pmr
personnes à mobilité réduite
ma mission telle c'est une personne âgée
isolée à quel moment il a sauvé à quel
moment il faut il faut mettre cette
personne à l'abri
ça peut créer une dynamique de quartier
et je connais aussi bien des exemples de
villes qui ont mené des expériences en
un mot un peu pompeux mitigation
sadiquement réduit au maximum la
vulnérabilité de territoire ou où les
conséquences de catastrophes
eh bien il ya des expériences vraiment
des projets de développement de tv3 qui
sont passés par là et nous courrons avec
le territoire aussi exposés à de
multiples risques
on ne parlera par quelques personnes
bien parler tu sais il ya pascal ça
fâche franck hubert à berric manceau
l'un quelques personnes qui en parle
à certains moments on en parle beaucoup
plus qu'à d'autres moments mais on n'a
pas l'impression qu'une prise de
conscience de la nécessité de faire de
cette question des risques et de la
résilience reininger majeur une entrée
de développement parce que ça plaît aux
niveaux par exemple des transferts de
technologie tout ce qu'on aura pu
trouver et c'est comme moyen de contenir
une cata société va ça peut être
transféré à porter ailleurs échangé avec
d'autres pays et c'est là c'est vraiment
une niche extraordinaire de
développement en plus d'être une
nécessité pour nous et pour notre
sécurité profession à sa richesse qu'il
ya dans le monde que ce soit dans la
caraïbe wire un des exemples desquels
nous pourrions nous inspirer dans tel ou
tel pays de justement de réaménagement
ou alors d'expérimentation grandeur
nature avec la population pour lui faire
prendre conscience de de l'incidence
dans sa vie quotidienne de tel ou tel
aléa ou de tel ou tel risque naturel
il existe on va parler du monde
insulaire il existe en effet des îles
qui sont bien plus avancés que nous en
matière de réflexion en matière de
réflexion de de leur aménagement
ceci dit c'est ils ont un avantage que
nous n'avons pas et qu'à la guadeloupe
c'est que ce sont des petits archipels
donc quand vous avez plusieurs petits
territoires si proches les uns des
autres
vous pouvez établir géant médias des
relations entre ces territoires et
spécialisés ces territoires vous avez
par exemple des territoires je pense à
l'océan indien qui ont spécialisé
certaines de leurs vives donc vous avez
des îles qui sont dédiés par exemple la
gestion des déchets de trois qui sont
dédiés à la production énergétique
d'autres qui sont dédiées à d'autres
choses et c'est en martinique
notre problème c'est que nous avons un
territoire qui est petit qui est en
effet soumis à toute la palette des
risques naturels ou quasiment
et c'est un territoire de surcroît qui
est très montagneux dont contraint donc
c'est sûr que quand on parle de
relocalisation quand on parle de toutes
ces expérimentations
elles peuvent être facilement mener à
l'échelle d'un territoire à l'échelle
d'une commune
quand il y a de surcroît la volonté
politique pour le faire mais c'est vrai
qu'après généraliser le processus ça
devient très vite compliqué j'ai pas dit
impossible mais je dis bien compliqué
pourquoi parce qu'il faut prendre
ensuite en compte tous les autres
facteurs c'est à dire que les
populations auraient pu être localisé à
tel endroit mais c'est une zone
inondable ou c'est une zone qui est
soumise au risque de glissement de
terrain ou c'est une zone agricole où
c'est une zone protégée il ya peut-être
un arrêté de biotope et c'est donc quand
on prend l'ensemble des éléments qu'il
faut prendre en compte quand on
considère l'ensemble de ces éléments on
s'aperçoit qu'en martinique les
possibilités qui nous sont offertes
pour relocaliser les populations les
déplacés ou en tout cas avoir un
aménagement beaucoup plus cohérent ces
possibilités se réduisent
progressivement à peau de chagrin parce
qu'il ya plein de choses qu'il faut
prendre en compte
alors c'est possible à l'échelle de
quartier c'est possible à l'échelle de
communes de certaines communes mais je
crois qu'il faut déjà commencer par là
vous savez on dit que l'appétit vient en
mangeant et on dit que c'est un il faut
faut mettre le premier pas pour pour
avancer mais je crois que là est le
prêcheur le fait trinité en train de
s'engager dans ce processus le carbet
est aussi à ses moteurs au niveau d'un
certain nombre de projets il faut déjà
s'en enfin peut-être pas s'enorgueillir
il faut déjà être satisfaits est
conscient que ça se fait peut-être pour
aussi donné l'envi à ceux qui sont dans
des situations peut être un peu plus
contrainte ou contraignantes mais de
réfléchir je crois qu'il ya toujours des
possibilités
même si elles sont modestes encore mais
il faut au moins faire le premier pas
problème c'est qu'on a certaines
municipalités on s'aperçoit pour
lesquels tout semble difficile tout
semble compliqué et pourtant il y a tant
à faire pour protéger les populations
est-ce que ça voudra dire que les
générations à venir sont seront obligés
d'avoir un mode 2 un mode de vie
différent de celui que nous avons
aujourd'hui que nos parents nos grands
parents ont eu personnellement j'en suis
convaincu moi je crois que si nous ne
prenons pas les bonnes décisions
aujourd'hui demain vivre en martinique
sera vraiment très différent
et quand cela sera cervera encore
possible dans certaines communes demain
sera très différent d'aujourd'hui
oui ça c'est évident parce qu'il y a des
communes qui de toute façon sont amenés
sinon à disparaître mais en tout cas
avoir leurs superficies fortement
réduite
il y a des communes qui sont qui
deviendront surpeuplé parce que il y
aura un afflux massif
on parlait de migration tout à l'heure
de migration interne il y aura un afflux
massif de
deux voisins et les voisins je ne parle
pas des îles voisines je parle bien des
voisins de ceux qui viennent des
communes voisines
parce que on va se replier sur certaines
communes et donc c'est vrai que les
relations humaines les relations
sociales risquent d'être parfois un peu
plus tendue ce que disait marc siano est
tout à fait exact
les populations qui ont été déplacées
dans notre histoire on parle de lame
antenne de l'événement de la montagne
pelée mais on parle aussi de on peut
prendre d'autres exemples même plus
récents à partir du moment où les
populations sont déplacées elles sont
toujours considérées comme des parias
elles sont toujours montrés du doigt
sont toujours stigmatisé et ça c'est un
vrai problème et même sur un territoire
aussi petit que la martinique donc il
faut aussi prendre ceci en considération
parce que je la juge a insisté jean fond
sur le cloud demain risque d'être
difficile et difficilement gérable si
aujourd'hui nous ne prenons pas un
certain nombre de décisions qui
s'imposent nous y reviendrons même
question pour marcellin nadeau le
meilleur du prêcheur seront obligés de
changer le mode de rue dans les années
qui viennent
sévit dans sa décision pour la question
des déchets le problème des élus c'est
les élus font preuve de bonne volonté et
sa vie quand je vois comment ils
s'efforcent de gérer les déchets en
martinique
mais même si les élus mettent toute leur
bonne volonté toute la bonne volonté du
monde il n'y a eu ni ziri n'y arriveront
pas si nous ne changeons pas de logique
parce que la question des déchets je
prends cet exemple là c'est de produire
le moins de déchets possible parce qu'il
ya la réalité physique de notre
territoire qui n'est pas extensible à
souhait pour traiter les déchets donc il
faut revoir nos modes de consommation
il faut revoir le système économique il
faut revoir nos modes de production
il faut reposer la question de la
relocalisation de l'économie d'abobo
foyer que tout cela en partant des
risques on peut aboutir une réflexion
plus large une réflexion globale qui
pose in fine et la question du système
et de sa logique
je crois qu'il est illusoire c'est un
auteur qui disait que le capitalisme
vert est impossible et oui je
m'interroge sur les capacités 2 du
système actuel que ça soit au niveau
planétaire le nez au liban
l'isthme dominant ce soit à l'échelle de
la martinique avec nos réalités jeudi à
néocolonial je ne crois pas qu'on sera
en mesure de s'en sortir il faut
accepter d au moins des espaces de
rupture avec une logique de système qui
est à bout de souffle qui nous mène
droit dans le mur et il faut surtout
veiller à lever le pied de
l'accélérateur parce que l'on va très
vite dans le mur la profession ça va je
vous disiez tout à l'heure que demain si
nous ne prenons pas des mesures
drastiques qui aurait dû déjà être
prises il ya 20 ans l'échelle de la
planète entière
demain sera difficile en quoi ce sera
plus difficile de manquer ce sera pire
si la com n'est pas inversée par exemple
qu'est ce qui sera qu'est ce que cela
implique compliqué mais ce qui sera plus
compliqué c'est que déjà tous les
indicateurs indiquent la population
alors là on va parler de façon globale
oui on peut parler de la martinerie rien
fait ils sont là la population ne cesse
de croître la la la courbe elle et elle
est vraiment très l'a pris comment
dirais-je d'une courbure qui indique que
la population mondiale ne va cesser de
croître
deuxièmement on s'éclate ceci implique
rouabah ceci implique très souvent une
déforestation importante et cette
déforestation a pour but de loger ces
populations de produire pour ces
populations dont une agriculture en plus
de plus en plus intensive de plus en
plus polluantes et on s'aperçoit en
réalité qu'on a un certain nombre de
territoires qui étaient des pieri
thouars qui jusqu'àlors était
relativement univers relativement
correctement et ses territoires
maintenant sont en train de se
paupériser sont en train de s'appauvrir
fortement parce que il n'y a plus de
ressources naturelles parce que les les
sources sont pollués parce que la
population qui se nourrissait
d'elle-même et obligés maintenant
d'acheter des produits d' et qu'elle n'a
plus les moyens de les acheter à ces
multinationales qui ont exploité ces
territoires et donc on est en train de
créer en fait un monde qui devient quasi
invivable il devient quasi invivable
parce qu'il a été
j'ai envie de dire donnez voir livrer à
des multinationales qui contrôlent
maintenant qu'ils contrôlent les
ressources naturelles voire parfois je
vais m je vais même plus loin qu'ils
contrôlent même parfois les
gouvernements donc quand on s'aperçoit
mais c'est une réalité dans certains
états en tout cas dans certains états du
sud on a des multinationales qui
contrôlent totalement les gouvernements
et donc cette réalité et je tiens à
préciser que je ne prenait absolument
pas la révolution
je prône simplement le réalisme
le réalisme c'est celui ci maintenant il
est possible d'en sortir avec un peu de
bonne volonté tout simplement il n'est
pas nécessaire vous savez de prendre les
armes ou de promener la grande
révolution de main en disant avec moi
demain on rasera gratis où tout ira
mieux non il est possible de changer de
logique tout simplement en étant
conscient que la nature a été là avant
nous elle le sera de toute façon après
nous et donc il faut s'adapter aux
réalités naturelles s'adapte aux
réalités naturelles ça ne veut pas dire
faire un bond en arrière parce que dès
qu'on dit ça on al impression qu on
revient autant de au temps des cavernes
où on s'éclairait encore en faisant du
feu n'ont fonctionné au rythme de la
nature ça veut dire respecter la nature
ça veut dire se servir de la nature mais
ne pas lasser revivre sur surtout ce que
ça veut dire et ne pas la servir ça veut
dire en puiser les ressources dont on a
besoin
mais ne pas épuiser ses ressources voilà
et je crois qu'à partir du moment où on
a compris qu'on peut se servir de la
nature mais sans la servir sans
l'épuiser et qu'elle nous permette
encore demain de manger qu'elle
permettait encore aux générations
suivantes de manger mais c'est possible
et c'est possible parce que dans
certains états ça fonctionne dans
certains pays ça marche donc si ça
marche ailleurs je ne vois pas pourquoi
ça ne fonctionnerait pas ici il faut
simplement le vouloir par contre il faut
une volonté
avons nous la volonté de changer de
système avons nous la volonté de sortir
de notre zone de confort de notre petit
notre petite bulle de jouissance telle
est la question
il se dit généralement selena d'eau que
l'homme est la seule espèce vivante qui
est son propre prédateurs est-ce qu'il
peut être un jour l'acteur de sa
réparation en quelque sorte son
réparateur
alors ceux issus cette réflexion c'est
vrai que j'avais peur disait qu'il
n'était pas révolutionnaire moi je verse
est passé
mais je ne sais pas si je le suis encore
mais bon s'ils se trouvent qui est de
l'évolution pourvu qu'elle n'ait pas de
conséquences humaines
pourquoi pas mais mais mais bon je vais
être pragmatique et je me définirais
plus comme une sorte de comme dirait
bien les berlines boere un réformiste
faut en tout cas réformiste radical
il faut alors il m'a si planus et font
mantas evry est ce que on va pouvoir
changer les hommes parce que c'est ça il
faudrait que l'on soit moins cupide ils
soient moins prédateurs qui pense plus à
l'autre etc
moi je crois effectivement je crois ou
deux aspects ça dit il faut d'une part
changer les conditions économiques
sociales et politiques du monde ça me
paraît évident mais en même temps elles
ne suffisent pas c'est une condition je
me dis est nécessaire mais pas
suffisante il faut changer l'homme
fondamental et je le crois de plus en
plus vers je suis pas si vieux que ça
enfin au fil du temps je crois que je
prends conscience aussi de la nécessité
de faire le pari de la sagesse des
hommes et sociaux de la commune bien
moins le dit fort bien il dit faisons
avec les hommes de bonne volonté ça nous
rappelle une phrase de la bible d'air
effectivement je crois qu'il faut des
fois fait aussi avec les hommes de bonne
volonté il faut changer les consciences
c'est le fameux principe d'expérience et
je crois que là aussi on appelle à
d'autres acteurs tout le temps fait
appel aux politiques les politiques les
politiques mais à d'autres acteurs de la
société
ce qu'on pourrait appeler la société
civile les églises par exemple bon je
crois que les églises on enrôle
notamment les églises singulière et 10
chrétienne en a beaucoup ici
mais son rôle à jouer dans la relation
l'environnement dans la relation à
l'homme dans la vision qu'on a du monde
le fait d'être toujours dans cette parce
que l'homme est un prédateur pour
l'homme c'est vrai mais justement
l'économie l'essence même de l'économie
néolibérale
c'est une économie de la prédation il
faut sortir de cette logique économique
de la prédation pour entrer dans une
logique de la coopération et c'est pas
la révolution se dérouler mois et s'est
décalé l'autre club basque aimant les
nids puisque l'aja qui met se dire qu'on
a peut-être qu'on a été chercher les
intérêts communs qu'on peut partager et
mutualiser un certain nombre de choses
dans le monde économique c'est cette
voie là qu'il faut point surtout surtout
dans un pays comme la martinique qui est
un pays avec sa dimension c'est pas un
petit pays
aussant ce humain c'est un petit pays
physiques qui font plein de fois j'ai
pas dis qu'on est petit mais justement
c'est parce qu'on est petit physiquement
il faut être grande dans l'âme et
développer les systèmes de coopération
pour permettre aux hommes et aux femmes
qui composent ce peuple-là de vivre de
meilleurs conditions alors je me tourne
quasiment pour les derniers modèles
émission un gagneur échangeurs le
révolutionnaire sa tendre vers le
professeur sa page parce qu'enfin dans
votre discours et décapante parce qu'en
réalité vous demander de prendre
conscience de nos faiblesses de nous et
en même temps de nos atouts est-ce que
foncièrement au fond de vous alors que
ça fait une vingtaine d'années que vous
êtes sur le terrain que vous voyez des
réalités que vous n'arrivez pas
forcément à faire entendre raison à nos
compatriotes puisque comme je l'aï dit
il s'agit pas de jeter la pierre aux
élus à l'état que sais-je encore et
c'est nous tous la population qui est
concerné est ce qu'il n'ya pas deux
chambres ont finalement seule usine
émoluments baisser mal parentis et il ya
plus rien à faire c'est trop tard je
crois que nous sommes déjà submergées
genre même année justement parce que on
peut glisser facilement vers cette
espèce d'état de désespoir qu'il ne faut
surtout pas le faire et qu'il faut
continuer à se battre en réalité je
crois que si les réalités quotidiennes
les réalités d'aujourd'hui en effet nous
incite à laisser tomber à nous dire de
toute façon il n'y a vraiment plus de
solution c'est c'est fini c'est foutu et
donc ne nous battons plus et laissons
les choses continuer à se dégrader non
je crois qu'il faut continuer à se
battre au contraire il faut continuer à
éclairer les uns et les autres à partir
de données qui sont des données
tangibles des données qui sont des
données scientifiques
je crois qu'il y arrive il n'y a que ces
éléments qui permettront peut-être aussi
aux uns et aux autres peut-être de
prendre conscience est bon il faut il
faut faire comme dans l'enseignement
enseigner c'est répéter donc répéter
inlassablement les mêmes choses alors
c'est vrai que parfois c'est un peu
désespérant de voir qu'on ne cesse de
répéter les mêmes choses sans qu'il y
ait forcément d'actes ou que ça ne bouge
vais tout de suite mais moi je
continuerai en tout cas à répéter à
répéter tout ce que j'ai toujours dit
c'est-à-dire que il est possible de
développer ce territoire en se servant
de l'environnement et sans trop dégrader
cet environnement je crois qu'il ya un
équilibre qui est totalement possible
entre les deux parce que très souvent on
a opposé le développement et la
protection de l'environnement je ne suis
pas interdit bob l'environnement je je
je je suis favorable la protection de
l'environnement
je ne suis pas je pense que le
développement passe aussi
par l'utilisation de l'environnement
mais une façon de l'utiliser mais par
contre ce qui me désespère c'est cette
espèce de comment comment comment vais
je vous dire le seul oui cette ambiance
que où on a le sentiment que on ne prend
pas conscience de la réalité on a un peu
l'impression d'être un peu en lévitation
pourtant les réalité s'impose à nous
elles sont là elles nous en elle nous
entoure et nous oppresse même mais on
continue à les ignorer allègrement parce
que nous sommes tous dans des sortes de
bulles un petit peu artificielle de
confort est sûre ce confort matériel
finira par nous tuer il finira par nous
tuer parce que nous ne prenons pas
conscience que le danger est à nos
portes et le danger c'est c'est cet
environnement que nous avons tellement d
tellement dégradées qu'il est en train
de nous faire payer justement les
dégradations que nous avons imposées
merci professeur ça fâche le mot de la
fin pour remercier les nadeau maire du
prêcheur v du local de proximité
avez-vous des raisons d'être optimiste
oui il faut rester optimiste mais en
même temps réaliste
vous savez on a l'impression qu'on ne
sait pas tirer les enseignements fait de
l'histoire quand je on sait qu' on
aurait pu on l'a échappé belle à voir
une usine au charbon en martinique
vous savez un premier projet biomasse
était une centrale au charbon alors que
le charbon ont le il est au fond on a
compris que le charbon déjà avec la
révolution l'a fortement contribuer au
changement climatique et que beaucoup de
pays se débarrassent de leurs centrales
au charbon on nous donnait ça il ya des
politiques martiniquais qui ont accepté
ça c'est pour ça que des fois je me dis
que il faut absolument une prise de
conscience non seulement des de la
réalité physique géographique avec les
risques mais du potentiel que nous avons
au niveau énergétique et je crois qu'il
faut aussi prendre la voie d'une
transition énergétique mais une voix
résolu de la france génétique de manière
à savoir aussi profiter de tout ce que
parce que la nature c'est vrai qu'elle
nous donne des des soucis et elle nous
fait courir de nombreux risques nous
expose à des risques mais en même temps
de cette nature dans notre pays est très
généreuse
on a le soleil on a le vent on a là
mais ce sont des sources de richesse
inestimable inépuisable et je crois
qu'il fait conscient à la fois des
richesses des atouts de notre pays
mais être aussi conscient des
difficultés liés à notre environnement
et aux réalités physiques deux pays et
quand le martiniquais soit conscient de
tout cela eh bien je crois que on aura
toutes les raisons d'espérer
et c'est ce que j'espère on est des
raisons d'espérer que nous ayons des
raisons d'espérer
merci en tout cas ma seule anna domérat
du prêcheur et profession parce que ça
fâche géographe ceni à l'université des
antilles d'avoir anticipé au premier
numéro de cette nouvelle formule de face
à la première émission que vous pourrez
retrouver un
si notre site internet la première point
fr ainsi que sur la page facebook de
martine première est également en radio
le dimanche à 12 ans durant toute la
saison je vous quitte en vous donnant
rendez-vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de face à la première qui
était réalisée aujourd'hui par patrice à
la guise à la chine à bientôt
face à la première
[Musique]